sta entrando dentro l'armadio lui
berlino il nuovo video come lino appunto
che sbadiglia sempre continuazione in
cui vedremo cosa fa merlino quando noi
non siamo a casa però questa volta starà
dentro casa perché se vi ricordate
l'altra volta abbiamo fatto il video
cosa fa merlino quando non siamo a casa
ma lui era fuori quindi in giardino
l'uomo visto che correva da una parte
all'altra insomma se non avete visto
andate qui a vederlo questo video
ma questa volta starà dentro casa
abbiamo un po di paura che faccia
qualche casino e che distrugga qualcosa
però stiamo anche super curioso di
vedere cosa succede lasciate un bel mi
piace se volete altri video con berliri
considerate sicure che altri video
volete giorni commetti lorenzi che farò
a berlino
allora sicuramente all'inizio piangerò
perché ogni volta che usciamo all'inizio
piange un pochino bomberino potessi st
primi commenti anche i vostri caioli
ugatti i tatti piangono i gatti piango
se anche loro piangono quando uscite di
casa poi sicuramente secondo mai
cercherà qualcosa per giocare oppure si
addormenterà e secondo te invece segue
dove dormirà e basta tutto ruota a
dormire per lino e già addormentato
infatti che cosa vorrai dormirò allora
come facciamo per vedere cosa farà
berlino in casa li mettiamo questa
pettorina in cui quasi mette una
videocamera l'abbiamo già testata sia
per l'altro video sia altre volte per
essere sicuri che non gli dia fastidio
mettiamo qua sul petto è la camera
registrerà tutto il tempo poi torniamo a
casa
mettiamo la schedina nel computer e
guardiamo
cota ha fatto berlino nel frattempo così
reagiremo assieme a voi siamo subito e
mettiamo la pettorina con la videocamera
berlino ecco abbiamo piazzato la camera
sopra berlino ora lazio niamo e noi
usciamo e vediamo che combina merlino
nella liga sei pronto
ok ragazzi siamo tornati che carine che
servirà ora gli tagliamo la pettorina e
andiamo a vedere assieme che cosa è
successo mentre non c'eravamo siamo
fatti via tipo 15 minuti più o meno non
tanto quindi non so se ha dormito tutto
il tempo o se ha solo pianto e dormito
vediamo berlino come stai
sei contento che siamo tornati passo è
bellissimo
ok siamo qui e ora stiamo per guardare
cosa ha fatto per l'incontro punto
d'amore
andiamo a cui l'avevamo messa gli stavo
dando dei giochini
così nel frattempo magari giocava con
qualcosa abbiamo già fatto ovviamente
proverà a seguirci importato è troppo
bello vederlo d'acqua i suoi gioiellini
questo gioco gli piacciono tantissimo la
carota aiuta la memoria pronti questo ma
cercando di uscire ma lui si seguiva ero
indeciso ancora si muoveva da una parte
all'altra sta sentendo i rumori adesso
se si sta agitando bambino che c'è penso
che adesso sta a me è andata
nell'entrata e mi sembra che noi usciamo
adesso sta dalla parte di via della
setta o kay noi siamo usciti mi sta
correndo perché fin cites e stiamo zitti
a controllare il vetro tutto sporco
perché merlino si appoggia sempre lì a
leccare ho visto che siamo usciti e sta
correndo all'ingresso perché
probabilmente ci sempre che stavamo
passando da lì è quindi andato subito ad
aspettare ha detto forse rientro di qua
ma ascoltando dove siamo e cosa con la
fascetta è troppo bello vederlo da
questa videocamera sembra di essere lui
continua ascoltata da dove saranno
andati si guarda intorno
sta cercando di capire che causeranno un
po per terra si sta guardando allo
specchio forse no questa con 26 punti
preferiti dove si stende il solito
[Musica]
contorno a controllare la casa casomai
magari siamo ricomparsi bocciate solo
kimi è andato in studio è salita infatti
che non riesce a salire su questo letto
perché un pochino più alto quindi si
mette solo quelle campi di davanti
carità osservando che se qualcuno che mi
alza legale alle zampe di dietro
purtroppo carino sembra che c'è il
bacchi i giochini sforzi di mercato è
tornato nell altro inglese sta passando
il termosifone controllando a
controllando perché suo figlio delle
scale sei una porta quindi ha
controllato s'era aperta o chiudiamo
l'abbiamo chiusa altrimenti girovagava
troppo chi sta ancora ascoltabile se ne
sono andati perché cari stiamo stampando
in camera vediamo cosa combina
[Applauso]
guardando dalla finestra ci stiamo e lì
si sta guardando lo specchio
troppo bello dentro l'armadio furbo
facendo per fortuna il sito lo fa
benissimo che non potrà che sta facendo
è andata sicuramente voleva rubare
qualche vestito smangiucchiate si stava
cercando nell'armadio sta nuovamente
controllando la porta di zoom se casomai
si è aperta così all'improvviso deciso
scendendo musicale o no
[Musica]
bella questa questa inquadratura amore
muro bianco perfetto ecco sta scendendo
le scale per me la gente le scale di
tutti porto però ha visto che la porta è
chiusa
vediamo cosa provavo fare dopo mi tocca
risalire adesso sta raddoppiando la
camera al muro
sta volando sopra le scale semplicemente
che i cani e pazzini sta pensando
allora se ero solo sopra non sono
neanche giusto sono sto meditando se si
guarda il muro bianco che medita addio
merli romano tiene noia starei lì fermo
a guardare il muro messi con tutti i
fiocchi micheli abbiamo lasciato che si
è appoggiato col musetto sull'altro
accendono le luci spente le luci rimasto
un orecchio
ok forse ferrari fare le scale con molta
calma
un gradino alla volta ok decisamente
risalendo le scale gradinata volta che
dovranno usare siamo passati di qui io
ne ero intelligente e certo però ci ha
visto che siamo usciti la quindi perché
dovremmo usare le scale
lei è la reale sta scadendo un po più
velocemente
[Musica]
ok a risalite le scalvi di apprezzare a
parte
si torna a fare sentire qui non solo
sociali ma leggendo le altre scale
oggi abbiamo appoggiato i suoi cecchini
o lui i continuatori della casa perché
in teoria non dovrebbe salire al piano
di sopra
però sa che non si stiamo e quindi
furbetto va a controllare sono cesare
luci ma perché laddove stesse aziende in
automatico sta andando la di controllare
la controllo da un pertanto gol del
pazzo non ci posso credere non è mai
andato lì mai aprire il controllato
tutto
dove si sono nascosti lo sta facendo
cadere la colonia in pratica è un un
coso di carta per fare le foto però è di
carta quindi merlino stabilito che non
può avvicinarsi lì altrimenti il loro
alto e subito se si appoggia e
ovviamente si è appoggiato dopo devo
andare controllare
vediamo se si guarda adesso mi sembra
ancora in piedi
stranamente dello stato è ancora in
piedi ancora in piedi
[Musica]
ok sta tornando il ju quindi sta
nuovamente se non mio cane che farà
adesso secondo me dopo tutto questa
esplorazione guarda si mette a dormire
sicuro micron è chiusa la camera ne
avete spaventata
ok è sceso nuovamente sta parlando in
studio alla camera la società si è
piegata si vede molto non si vede più la
sua testa perché è un po l'insula camera
destra scendendo le scale ed ha sbattuto
mannaggia è stato intanto lei lo sa
benissimo che non deve salire glielo
diciamo sempre che urbane
ovviamente dorme adesso a scorrimento
peccato che la camera costa un'altra
cosa
cielo il suo testolin overall e tra
sbadigliando penso che se sia
addormentando ancora non parli chi sente
i rumori sa che belli padroncini non ci
sto non posso stare a letto perché
chrome furgone è rimasto a letto per un
sacco di tempo furbetto
ed è ciò che devo aspettare allineano
l'aspetto comodo ha sentito che siamo
rientrati guidate lamazzi troppo
contento subito s
[Musica]
che cari subito attore docenti quindi
quello che ha combinato berlino cosa
quando la leal eravamo a casa ma la via
è divertiti troppo vederlo ovviamente io
non avevo dubbi che si mettesse a
dormire
non mi aspettavo ci mettesse a dormire
sul letto questo furbo capitano che tali
due entrate nella porta
scriveteci nei commenti e lasciateci il
minuto il time stamp del momento che vi
ha divertito di più così poi andremo a
rivederli tutti quanti lasciate bel mi
piace se volete vedere altri video con
berlino e ora vi lasciamo la casellina
puoi cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]